[Music]
robert uh
is in saint louis hey robert welcome to
the ramsay show
hey guys um my wife
and i have been married about seven
months so we're pretty newlyweds
um and she has about a hundred and five
thousand student loans
um we may combine about 120 000 a year
my my question is uh the the mark the
housing market right here is
red hot so i'm thinking if we sold our
house i could conservatively make about
130 grand on it and basically cover
all of her loans wow um
my parents live close by and they've
offered to let us move in
and kind of rent to own um
while they you know they bought a condo
down in florida so they
they'd be back and forth you know um to
the house and whatnot but
they've offered us to you know live in
it
just pay rent them rent and then we
could make whatever updates we wanted to
the house and
you know eventually when they pass away
it'd be ours so
no that part i'm not doing um
no thank you uh that that's too that's
too weird to plan
for for her uh right
uh but i i i would i sell the house
uh what and just go rent something
and be debt-free man i'd be really
tempted
yeah i wouldn't do the whole parent
thing though yeah that's scary
okay yeah i wouldn't even i don't think
that's good for your marriage
especially in the first year yeah
you all need freedom and peace that's
papa dave advice that's not financial
advice but um
yeah i just i i wouldn't i no i i
i i think that's got too many weird
strings
and twisted up uh uh spiderwebs tied to
the deal and it's
it's strung out and it's you know sort
of your house but they sort of might
come home and live there some and
it's back and forth so no i just go rent
you a place yeah if you want to sell the
house and be debt-free that's not a bad
idea
it's nothing in the world if you don't
you can be debt-free fairly quick making
120 anyway if you just lean into it
but if you guys just say well the house
isn't our favorite we'll go rent for two
years
and we'll be debt-free and we'll save up
and let this housing market calm down
and buy again
um that would be okay
but uh you don't have to but if you just
you know
but i wouldn't do the parent part of it
are you hearing i mean no
dave i was i was like no no i'm not
doing it
i mean because mom and dad can come home
whenever they want
and we're just now newly married we're
still getting to know each other i don't
want to get to know her and her get to
know my parents at the same time
like we need we need freedom we need
peace um
we we need our own privacy you know and
so i would just go
whatever you're going to pay them for
rent go rent an apartment yeah and just
start stacking up your bread
and then once you get your money back up
go go get the house that you all want
uh eventually but i i would not sign an
agreement with
mom dad mother-in-law father-in-law
right now i just wouldn't do it yeah
i agree that's that's the only part of
it sounds weird but i
i i'm on the fence as to whether i'd
sell or not i i'm
selling a house to get out of debt is
the last thing i do
right i try everything else unless you
just don't like the house
yeah isn't that the question like if if
if you had no debt would you still want
to sell the house
yeah if we were thinking about selling
anyway yeah um
of course you the problem is if you sell
in this high market you got to buy in
this high market so
you've got both sides of this uh i mean
you get you just walk out on the plank
doing that but that that's uh um
i don't know i i i'm 50 50 on it's not a
bad idea
but i think it i think the answer to the
question is should you sell houses
really
do you just don't care about the house
anyway are you only doing this for debt
and i love the house and i hate to part
with it
then i'd probably sit there and fight
through the debt or i hate the house and
this is an excuse to get rid of it and i
get out of debt ding ding we're out of
there there you go
go rent for a little bit that's probably
the way you answer the question
and then just avoid the whole parent
trap thing